المترجم: wafaa al onazi
المدقّق: Hanaa Yehia
مساء الخير
وماهي أفكار الغرب عنا؟
وهل هي افكار سيئة أو حسنة عنا كسعوديين
في بدايات عملي في مستشفى Mass Eye & Ear
في بوسطن منذ سنة وعلم زملائي أنني سعودية
سألتني احدى زميلاتي، "وفاء، ماذا ستعملين
عند عودتك للسعودية؟ هل يوجد مستشفيات؟
هل ستغيرين تخصصك عند عودتك؟"
صدمني السؤال! هل هي جادة؟
مجرد مزحة؟ أو أنني لم أفهم قصدها؟
ماهو توقعكم؟
كانت جادة. كل ماتعرفه عن السعودية
أنه لا توجد فيها مستشفيات
صدمتني المعلومة وأحزنتني في نفس الوقت.
أنه مازال هناك من يعتقد أننا
لا نملك أبسط الأشياء
مباشرة فتحت خرائط قوقل
لأريها أماكن المستشفيات في السعودية
والمستشفى الذي عملت به في الرياض
قبل قدومي لبوسطن منذ خمس سنوات
لم أرغب أن تمر اللحظة
دون أن أصحح معلومة خطأ
نحن للكثير من المجتمعات الغربية،
شعب مجهول و بلد مجهول خارج نطاق التطور.
كل ما يعرفوه عنا هو البترول، الإرهاب،
الصحراء والخيام.
لا يعرفون أو لم يصلهم التحديث الأخير
عن السعودية، أننا شعب متطور ومتمدن.
لا يعرفون أن الصحراء للتخييم والتطعيس
للسعوديين في نهاية الاسبوع من باب التسلية
والبترول هو تعويذة تطور هذا الشعب.
من البترول درسنا، ابتعثنا،
بنينا جامعات، مستشفيات
وساعدنا أنفسنا ومن يحتاج المساعدة
والإرهاب نحن أول متضرر منه.
قدمنا كثير شهداء من مصلين ورجال أمن.
صح ولا لا؟
هذا الموقف أيقظني من غيبوبة ثقافية
كما أحب أن أسميها.
وأستوعب أن هناك الكثير
ممن لايعرفوننا جيداً.
لكن أنا لا أستطيع تغيير الكثير
لو نفترض على نطاق بوسطن حيث أعيش.
لن استطيع تغيير فكر كامل المدينة عنا.
لكن أستطيع أن أغير من خلال الناس
الذين يمرون في حياتي، في مكان عمل،
أو غيره
ولو افترضنا أنني لم أستطع تصحيح أو تغيير
الصورة السيئة عن بلدي إلا مع شخص واحد
(زميلتي التي تعتقد أنه لامستشفيات لدينا)
فهذا كافي بالنسبة لي.
لأنها سوف تنقل المعلومة الصحيحة لأهلها
وأصدقائها. وهم بدورهم ينقلوها لغيرهم.
وهكذا تنتقل الصورة الصحيحة لعدة أشخاص
مثلما انتقلت الصورة النمطية السيئة.
بعد ذلك بدأت بمدونة أكتب فيها عن ثقافتي
وثقافات مختلفة تعرفت عليها.
اردتها أن تكون جسر بين الثقافات ولمسة
شفاء للجرح الثقافي بيننا.
وأيضاً منصة لفتح
باب الحوار الموصد بين الثقافات.
لأنه عندما يكون هناك سوء فهم بيني وبينك،
لا أريد أن أسمع منك أو أتعاطف معك.
والعكس صحيح. أنت عندما لا تعرفني
لن تتعاطف معي
وأي معلومة سيئة تسمعها عني سوف تصدقها
في نهاية المطاف كلنا نستطيع التغيير
ليس شرطاً ان أكون سياسيّاً
أو مشهوراً حتى أستطيع
تغيير صورة نمطية سيئة عن بلدي أو عني كشخص
وهذا ما قام به محمد.
محمد طالب في بوسطن
ومرتاد شبه دائم لمقهى جورج هاول
وصديق لصاحب المقهى والعاملين فيه.
أحب أن يترك في بوسطن خلفه أثر جميل.
فقام بتقديم القهوة العربية مع التمر
لكل المتواجدين في المقهى.
كانت هذه المرة الأولى للكثير منهم
لتجربة القهوة العربية
فنجان قهوة واحد فتح لهم باب من المقهى في
بوسطن ليطلوا منه على السعودية.
وبدأوا يتعرفون بشكل بسيط على السعودية
والسعوديين.
من أنت؟ من أي بلد؟
هذه القهوة تمثل أي ثقافة؟
لماذا تقدم هكذا؟ ( فنجان صغير وكمية قليلة)
لماذا لونها فاتح؟ وأسئلة أخرى
تعدت القهوة ليسألوا عن ثقافته ومن أين هو؟
وكيف الناس تعيش حياتها في بلده؟
وصور نمطية سمعوها في الإعلام
لكن لم تتح لهم فرصة للتأكد منها
وكانت هذه فرصة ليسألوا أحد من أهل البلد،
وفرصة لمحمد ليروج لثقافته وبلده.
لولا الصداقة بين محمد وصاحب المقهى،
لما حدث هذا الترويج الثقافي.
فنجان قهوة واحد روّج لكرم الضيافة
وحب المشاركة في مجتمعنا.
وحتى هذا اليوم، الدلة والفناجين معروضين
في المقهى.
حسناً!
ماهو الترويج الثقافي الذي قام به محمد؟
ماذا يعني ترويج ثقافي؟
الترويج الثقافي هو ببساطة تعريف ثقافي.
قبل كل شيء لابد أن تكون واعي لقيمك
ومبادئك واختلافاتك عن الثقافات الأخرى.
قبل ان تروج لها. وفي نفس الوقت
هو وعيك وفهمك لاختلافات الثقافات الأخرى.
ماذا يميزها عنك او ما يميزك عنها
حتى يسهل التواصل بينكم.
ثقافتك هي جواز سفرك.
تحملها معك مثلما تحمل جوازك واسمك
أينما ذهبت.
في الحقيقة ثقافتك هي تذكرة عبورك
لقلوب ووجدان الثقافات الأخرى.
طيب كيف نستطيع الترويج لثقافتنا
نحن كأفراد؟
أولاً، نفعل كما فعل محمد،
نكون صداقات مع الآخر
ثانياً، نرى أنفسنا كمواطنين لهذا الكون
قبل أن نصنف أنفسنا كمواطنين لأي بلد معين.
و نتعامل بإنسانية مع بعضنا البعض.
أنا أحترم وأقدر وأقبل الآخر كما هو
لا أحاول تغيره حتى لا يحاول هو تغييري.
عندما أتقبل وأحترم الآخر وأكوّن صداقة
مع المختلف عني
هذا الآخربدوره سوف يحترمني
ويتقبلني ككل، كثقافة وكشخص.
وسيحترم تصرفاتي معه،
وهكذا أستطيع أن أروج لثقافتي عنده.
وفي نفس الوقت هذا الشخص المختلف
سيروّج لثقافته
سوف تتعرف عليه وعلى بلده وثقافته،
فالموضوع بسيط.
فالترويج الثقافي هو تبادل ثقافي.
إذا لم تتقبل ثقافة غيرك،
لن تستطيع الترويج لثقافتك.
وفي تجربة ترويج ثقافي أخرى،
شبيهة بتجرية محمد،
دُعيت أنا لمعرض فني في بوسطن
لفنانة صديقة، كرستين.
وهي برفيسورة سابقة في جامعة بوسطن.
أقمت عندها لمدة سنتين وتعرّفَت على الثقافة
السعودية والعربية من خلالي.
ودعتني لأكون ضيف متحدث
في معرض فني لها،
وعنوانه الصمت.
وطلبت مني أن أحضرمرتدية العباءة.
أنا لا أرتدي العباءة في بوسطن.
ربما تتساءلون لماذا هذا الطلب؟
لماذا طلبت مني لبس العباءة.
وطلبت مني كذلك إحضار اثنتين من صديقاتي
مرتديات العباءة؟
أحضرتهما فعلاً وكانت إحداهما من عُمان
والأخرى من السعودية.
في المجتمعات الغربية لديهم صورة ذهنية..
امراة سعودية أو عربية + عباءة = الصمت
وهذا كان عنوان المعرض.
هذه المرأة المرتدية للعباءة
لا أحد يسمع صوتها،
ولا تعبر عن رأيها.
وكان حضورنا بالعباءة هو تحفيز لهم
وإثارة لتساؤلاتهم
حتى يسألونا أكثر عندما يرونا هكذا
ونحن موجودات
وتذكير لهم لأخبار وقصص سمعهوها عنا
ولا يعرفون مدى صحتها.
ونستطيع الآن الإجابة وتصحيح الصورالمغلوطة،
وأيضا كانت دعوة لهم حتى يروا أن هذه المرأة
ليست صامتة، وأن اللباس ليس مقياس لشخصية
الإنسان أو للحكم عليه إن كان ذا رأي أو لا
هذه المرأة ( الصامتة بنظرهم) تطورت وتثقفت،
وتعلمت وأصبحت جزء من تطور بلدها إن لم تكن
هي المساهم الأول في كثير من
التطورات بالسعودية.
وبدأ الحضور في المعرض يسألون عن العباءة.
لماذا ترتدينها؟
لماذا لونها أسود؟
وهل هناك ألوان أخرى؟
هل هي نفس العباءة طول السنة
أو تستبدلوها ؟
هل تنامون بالعباءة أو ترتدوها داخل البيت؟
هل هناك لباس معين ترتدينه تحت العباءة؟
كيف تختلف عن البرقع الأفغاني؟
هل هو قطعة واحدة أو أكثر؟
وأسئلة أخرى عنا كثقافة وكشعب.
كيف نعيش حياتنا اليومية؟
يريدون أن يعرفوا هل نشبهم؟
هل حياتنا اليومية تشبه حياتهم؟
هذا كل مايريدون أن يعرفوه،
بماذا نحتلف عنهم؟
نحن بشرمثلهم ونتشارك نفس الهموم .
نسعى خلف دراستنا، وظيفة احلامنا،
نتملك بيت،
نتزوج وننجب أطفال ونكون آباء صالحين،
يعني كلنا مثل بعض.
إذا اختلف زيّنا لا تختلف رغباتنا وقيمنا.
متطلباتنا الأساسية هي نفسها في أي مكان.
في نهاية المعرض،
شكرنا أحد الحضور وقال:
"لقد أخذتونا في رحلة سريعة للسعودية"
وكأن العباءة كانت بساط الريح الذي نقلهم
خلال ساعة ليزوروا السعودية
ويعود بهم لبوسطن.
بعد المعرض كرستين قررت
أن تدخل في تجربة فنية،
وأن تلبس العباءة لمدة ٢١ يوم،
كتضامن مع المرأة السعودية،
ولتبين لمجتمعها أن العباءة مجرد قطعة قماش
لا يقـيّــم الشخص إن كان سيّئاً أو حسناً.
كرستين تقول لي ولكم: "إن الحياة قصيرة،
وربما لاتسعفنا أن نزور كل مكان في العالم.
لكن نستطيع أن نتعرف على أي ثقافة أو بلد
دون أن نبرح أماكننا أو نسافر"
وهذا ما قامت به كعمل فني لها،
وكترويج ثقافي لنا كشعب.
الفن هو وسيلة جميلة للترويج الثقافي
لأن أي شئ ممكن ومقبول في الفن.
لا يوجد صح أو خطأ،
حلال أو حرام، هو مجرد فن.
وبعيداً عن الفن والقهوة،
نذهب لعالم الجريمة.
في أحد أيام عملي في المستشفى في بوسطن،
أتت إليّ إحدى زميلاتي، وهي جندية متقاعدة
من الجيش الأمريكي، تعمل بالمستشفى معنا
وقالت أنها كانت على وشك ارتكاب جريمة
ليلة امس.
هي تحمل سلاحها معها دائما بعدما تقاعدت
قلت لها باندهاش: " ما الذي حصل؟"
قالت: "كنت أتنزه في الغابة
القريبة من بيتي،
ولمحت تجمع ناس كبير
لم أره من قبل هنا
واقتربت بهدوء لأرى عن قرب
ما الذي يحدث،
وعندما اقتربت كان هناك رجل ملتحي ويحمل
بين يديه شئ تم لفه بقماش أبيض
ويقطر دماً!
وأيقنت أن هذا إنسان مقتول وهناك جريمة.
تردّدت ماذا أفعل؟
هل أتدخل لأني أحمل سلاح؟
كنت على وشك أن اتدخل
لدي ثوانٍ فقط لأقرر،
أتدخل او أتصل بالشرطة؟
ربما يكونُ مسلح!
كانت ثواني حتى أصل لقرار،
وخلال هذه الثواني
لمحت أطفال ونساء خلف هذا التجمع.
وكأن الصوره تحركت ورأيتها من زاوية اخرى.
وبدأت أربط بين هذه الصور التي أمامي وبين
ما أخبرتني به منذ يومين.
وتبيّن لي أن ذلك المحمول بالقماش
لم يكن
إلا...........
خروف العيد (الأضحية)
والموجودون هم مسلمون يحتفلون بعيد الاضحى."
أنا قبل ذلك بيومين طلبت إجازة ليوم واحد،
للاحتفال بعيد الأضحى،
وسألتني عنه وأخبرتها..
نهاية هذه القصة كانت ستكون مختلفة
لو أنها ما سألتني عن المناسبة،
أو لو أنني لم أجبها.
كانت النهاية بالتاكيد ستكون مختلفة.
صدقوني كانت ارتكبت جريمة أو اتصلت بالشرطة،
وأفسدت عليهم فرحة الاحتفال بالعيد.
فمشاركة اختلافاتنا مع الآخرهي مفتاح..
مفتاح لإزالة سوء الفهم بيننا.
وحتى يرى الآخر الأمر كما هو
بدون تكهنات.
لتبين لهم أنك شخص عادي
يحتفل بمناسبة دينية ولست إرهابي
كلنا نستطيع التغيير. أنا وأنت نستطيع
الترويج لثقافتنا،
وترك آثرجميل في مكان ما.
أنا أحب ان اسمي هذا الأثر أثر الفراشة.
أثر الفراشة هو أي أثر صغير تقوم به
ويترك أثر أكبر من الفعل.
هو مصطلح فيزيائي وفلسفي للأشياء الصغيرة
التي تترك أثر أكبر منها بعد ما تزول
كم عدد سكان المملكة؟
٣٢ مليون نسمة.
لو كل شخص ترك أثر فراشة في مكان ما،
وروّج لثقافته بطريقته.
كم أثر فراشة سيكون لدينا؟!
٣٢ مليون أثر فراشة. أي مملكة فراشات.
محمود درويش يقول لكم: "أثر الفراشة لا يُرى
لكن أثر الفراشة لا يزول."
وشكراً
(تصفيق)